tout le monde alors encore une partie de
l'équipe il a à nouveau les noirs ils
jouent contre un joueur je sais jamais
trop entendu parler freeman sergei
nikolaevitch donc joueur soviétique et
dont une partie
à saint-pétersbourg en 1914 donc en fait
c'est avant la première guerre mondiale
près des futurs vidéo on reprendra après
la première guerre mondiale qui a éclaté
en fait pendant que les kings joueront
un tournoi à mannheim en allemagne donc
l'apapus dans le tournoi après les
problèmes il s'est fait attraper il a
fui fin bref des histoires
rocambolesques
on verra son poing ont parlé après jadot
mieux renseignés bien faire investir
mais toujours est-il wallace et avant
donkey jours en russie enfin way mesure
soviétique et c'est parti là les noirs
donc d4 d5 donc très classique qui avait
les 3 4 6 et 4 6 granby dame
hélas les blancs font sous g5 un peu
rare bon bien sûr plus habituel de voir
qu'à ic3 le candidat mme classique voire
g3 qui mène à la catalane mais donc
toucher 5 il a fait h6 les blancs ont
retiré le fouga renflouage est en fait l
est qui dans la profité pour prendre ses
cadres et donc son idée c'est de
s'accrocher à ce pion est aussi se dire
comme le fou n'est plus là peut-être
tirer profit de cette diagonale affaibli
du hockey les blanches damas quatre
échecs faut récupérer le pion qui a aidé
cette et aidé à me prends c'est ok et en
récupération bombes allaient nord joue
le coup hyper classique dans les grands
vidame quoi qu'ils essaient 5
donc c'est pour ça qu'on dit toujours
c'est mieux de mettre kalila quand ces 6
quand le pion n'a pas été poussé parce
que on veut tôt ou tard rétablir
l'équilibré au centre carter et blanc
ont davantage d'espacé la capture bien
placé il prend des cases les noirs
jouent plus souvent sur trois rangées
mais le fait donc de jeu c'est 5 onces
ou florent prendre l'espace les blancs
sont nuls pts et 3 est là et noir font
encore un coup très classique et a6 avec
quelle idée faire b5 gagner à temps sur
l'adam et eve elles feront pas de
cadeaux donc l'idée que les blancs ou
voulu empêcher mais ça marche pas bien
ils ont fait à 4
en fait c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau
alors quand même b5 joli coup problème
pour les blancs secs en cas de prise
puis on prend et devant la dac à la fois
la dame est à la fois la tour donc on
gagne en même temps du coup b5
les ventes doivent reculer la dame ces
quatre dates encore reculé époux blaise
est du coup les noirs ont tous développé
tout bien mis et
les autres superposition les blancs prix
en v5 les mares aussi hélas bon il faut
toujours membre les blancs sont les
prendre ce pion c'est vrai qu'à première
vue on voit pas pourquoi la réputation
juste on perd encore du temps pour le
développement est sûrement qu'il fallait
ici un coup comme 3 mais ça c'est pas
vraiment sortir les blancs de tous leurs
problèmes
c'est alors je me couchais 5 le g3 fou b
4e cavalier suivi par cavaillé aux 4
on rajoute de la pression dans la
position est quand même très pénible
pour les blancs mais ok je vais pas dire
que ce soit perdant non plus juste très
chiant d'être avantage noir ok il
apprend b5 pas fous les quatre échecs le
guérillero revient g5 des clowns cavalli
f6 gagne un temps sur le fond qui bouge
et qui a eu lieu quatre en fait c'est du
coup dont je parlais mais sauf que les
blancs ont eu d'orage veut 3 et faut 2
ils ont jusqu'à éprouver 5-3 retour et
oviedo préemption mais maintenant web
défense a déjà bon ben ali tente et là
dessus avec les normes fixées b6 et en
fait ce qu'il veut faire c'est pas un
jeu qui allie à 4 voire peut-être qui
est des cinq pour remettre de la
pression sur ce cavalier b6 mon ordi
suggérait de prendre en photo
c'était très bien comme dame prend et
faire petit rac son idée c'est que après
un coup comme eux trois ils veulent
juste faire d'un v8 proposé changé d'âme
s'ils prennent tout reprend en fait on
est tellement rapide
on va rêver la con il ya un espion
voilà donc vitesse égale aux réflexes
quoi mais il fait dames c'est un dans la
variante nous disons qu'ils ne changent
pas et on rajoute de la pression et
d'awa 5 du coup on attaque à 3 ans et 3
ils vont pas arriver à défendre et sur
un coup comme disent on vous prend c4 se
développant en prenant un pion entoure
ces huit attaques le four rajoute une
charge là dessus si l'élan sauve le flou
boum boum boum d'un bouche découverte
voilà je mon matos ira d'ailleurs voilà
en dames et de mes deux échecs et mat
c'est un exemple
ouais donc en fait ici le pré dames
c'est un le tour prend de prendre un
petit roeulx 2008 c'était excellent mais
qui investissent très bien tourcoing
82.8 il tente qui a aidé de un peu pour
des clous et mais bien joué en fait il
prend juste problème donc les bons fait
roi prend parce que sur dang tran vient
dame un peu pas quoique le cavaliere il
plaît pas il peut c'est légal mais c'est
par une dame est sûre d'amis ici un peu
d'âme prend b2 essuyé un refus de
défense donc la cata alors il fera
prendre ben adama deux profitent du
cloud à en croire des liens bon ils se
cachent ils attaquent un peu la dame
avec le cavalier du coup dame b train et
chaque dame c2 et là mon goût france et
3 par les blancs ont repris et de la
recette similaire à la partie
en fait c'est de la même position mais
s'il prend puis on prend puis on prend
les blancs font foulée d'un fond flou 4
est en fait l'idée ça va être d'amener
ce pur adam on va avoir la même position
dans la partie donc je reprends juste
avant c'était juste pour illustrer donc
dû dams et 3 français 3 il a pris en b
est élu à fait fou et 4 donc la même
chose et ce prise donc comme j'ai dit on
va mais ce qu radars si les blancs font
brasser un sapeur illico haussier qui
c'est quatre suivi par b2b 1 est en fait
tiré d'affaires il a fait 3 usb 2 duo à
vendre parce que bah c b1 dame au
prochain coup vont eu partie ou pas il
voit une très bonne partie il a juste
massacré l'adversaire il a vu le b5
rapide mais il a fait tous les thèmes
importants dans vidame donc si vous
laisse avec les noirs sont importantes
connaître un peu ces partis classiques
où tout se passe bien
bon bien sûr l'adversaire n'est pas
obligé d'être aussi complaisant on va
dire dans sa manière de jouer mais voilà
toujours bon à savoir et comment réputé
conversation map
voilà bah on se retrouvera bientôt donc
pour les parties d'après guerre après
pour aller qui ou quoi allez à bientôt
au revoir